Let's go next to Zayla from Rhode Island.
Zayla from Rhode Island. You're on the air.
Zayla from Rhode Island, yes.
Sorry, it took me a while to meet myself.
How are you doing today? I'm doing well, thank
you. So you did a video actually very recently
about dog whistles and you discussed dog whistles
used on the right and dog whistles that might be
used as on the left. And you mentioned that
some of the leftist dog whistles are either
boring or there's not too many of them. I didn't
see you mention, though. Sometimes I feel like
even the worst use of the word ugly can be
considered a dog whistle by both the right
and the left, usually on the right, it's referring
to like their hatred of Jewish people on the left
or the extremists sometimes just use it as
like a catch all for like capitalists, like
just like capitalism in general. Some
of the more socialist types use it in
that way. Or what do you think about that?
I don't you know, so you're certainly right
that sometimes when the left uses the term
elites, they're talking about economic elites,
which applies to rich people and corporate CEOs
and that type of thing. I guess I don't I'm not
saying I don't know that it's a dog whistle in the
sense that everybody understands what they mean by
that. One of the things about dog whistles is when
you blow a dog whistle, the dog hears it. But,
you know, humans don't really hear it. So I just
would disagree that it's definitely a it's coded
language, but it's coded language. Everybody seems
to sort of understand. So I don't know that elites
in that usage really counts as a dog whistle.
That makes sense, actually, that now that
you mention that. Excellent. Well,
that's really the only question I had
prepared. So I just hope you're happy and
hope you're doing well and keeping warm.
Thank you. Yes.
Zayla from Rhode Island, appreciate
the call. Remember, everybody, the lesson from
from Zayla there is always make sure to set your
discord to silent or do not disturb or whatever
it is so we don't hear those annoying noises.